[MUSIC PLAYING]
RACHEL MYERS: Hi, I'm Rachel.
I'm a software engineer on
Firebase Security Rules.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT:
And I'm Sebastian.
And I work on Firestore.
Rachel, do you still remember
what happened last May?
RACHEL MYERS: How
could I forget?
That was the month that
I was flooded with emails
from every website I
had ever signed up for.
I looked at that flood
and I wondered why I ever
signed up for so many things.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: Last May,
the General Data Protection
Regulations took effect.
This legislation touches
on pretty much every aspect
of user data collection.
Among other things,
it regulates how
app developers are able to use,
collect, and store user data.
It was one of the biggest
changes to user privacy
that happened in a while but
the basics of user privacy
remained the same.
If you're building an app
that handles user data,
user privacy should be
one of your top concerns.
Today, Rachel and I will
show you some of the tools
that we have built
at Firebase to help
you respect your user's data.
Since neither of us are lawyers,
we cannot give you legal
advice.
Instead, we are going to treat
user privacy like software
developers and stick to what
we know best as engineers.
We will tell you
how Firebase can
help you with your
users' privacy
and share our personal
suggestions along the way.
By not just focusing
on GDPR, we hope
that what you will
learn today will
be applicable to
all of your users.
After all, user privacy
is larger than any one
piece of legislation.
Even before last May, different
regulations around user privacy
applied to users
in most countries.
Rachel and I don't know what
the future of data privacy
will look like.
Instead, we will talk about the
Firebase tools and principles
that you can already use
today to build products
that put your users in control.
But first, let us
explain what Firebase is.
We built Firebase so
that app developers
can focus on the features
that make their app unique.
We don't want you to have to
spend your time spinning up
a backend service just so that
you can store a bit of data.
Firebase takes mundane tasks
out of building an app.
We want to be with you from
your very first line of code
until you reach planet scale.
Maybe you've heard
of Firebase before.
It's OK if you haven't.
We shipped our first product
in 2012, the Firebase RealTime
Database.
Since then, we've been
growing our offerings
and have been watching
what customers
are doing with our products.
In 2016, we introduced
the Firebase SDKs
for Cloud Storage.
Cloud Storage for
Firebase allows
you to build apps that
let your users securely up
and download files
from Google's cloud.
We gracefully handle
poor network connectivity
and use Cloud
Storage's excaching
to offer superior performance.
And in 2017, we introduced
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
Cloud Functions
for Firebase allows
you to run your own server
site code without forcing
you to setup your own servers.
Cloud Function uses event-driven
lightweight JavaScript
that runs when data on
the backend changes.
And just last year, we
launched Cloud Firestore.
Clouds Firestore is a scalable
database for mobile web
and server development.
We offer feature rich SDKs
that integrate directly
with the Firebase platform.
Our SDKs support direct
from mobile access
and allow you to write
customer facing apps
without the need for
application servers.
Today, Firebase
offers 17 products
that help you develop, grow,
and earn from your mobile apps.
All of our products are built
around one core principle.
We want you to build apps
with rich backend integrations
without having to set up
these backends yourself.
RACHEL MYERS: We're in the
business of storing data.
So naturally, we've put a lot
of thought into a question
that you or your CIO
might have asked recently.
Do we handle those
privacy requirements
when we're building
Serverless apps?
User privacy was traditionally
not a concern for developers
when they were evaluating
Serverless backends.
The questions that you
would use when you're
evaluating Serverless
products were
things like what features
does this platform offer?
How will the parts of
this interact together?
And how well will each
component scale up for me?
By contrast, the
concerns that you
have when you're thinking
about user privacy
are pretty different.
Those are things like
how do we make sure
that my data is secretly stored?
How will I make sure that
my users understand the data
that I'm collecting?
And how will I make sure
that I remove the data
when I no longer need it?
So it doesn't seem like
there's a lot of overlap
between these two
types of questions.
Some people have even suggested
that Serverless architecture
and data privacy could
even contradict each other.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: Seems like
Rachel is reading my mind.
RACHEL MYERS: Or like we
wrote the talk together.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT:
But let's be honest,
even though I deeply
care about user privacy,
I am not willing to give up
Serverless development just
yet.
I don't want to go back
to the days of installing,
maintaining, and upgrading
my very own MySQL instances
just so that my Android app
can receive a single push
notification.
Fortunately, Serverless design
patterns and user privacy
can often go hand in hand.
At Firebase, we are proud to
offer products and tools that
help you protect
your users' data,
not despite, but because of,
our Serverless offerings.
Let's dive in and take a
look at a few examples.
RACHEL MYERS: We'll
start by showing you
how you can reduce the
data that you're storing.
And you can use
Firebase's Cloud Functions
to make sure that you're
managing this data well.
We'll show you examples of user
data deletion and user data
export.
Hit the clicker.
Sebastian and I
will dive into how
you can use Firebase's
security rules to limit
the access that people
have to your data
and how you can also
describe data ownership.
And we'll discuss notifying
your users about the data
that you are collecting.
That includes covering the
storage retention policies
for our backend.
And we'll show you
patterns for how
you can store those privacy
preferences once users
have given them to you.
And we'll end with
some advanced use cases
like activity logs to track
changes to privacy settings.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT:
Rachel and I want
you to design your apps
for privacy from the very
first line of code.
The easiest way to do
this is, of course,
to not store any data.
RACHEL MYERS: Sebastien,
not store any data?
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: OK.
Let's stay realistic and only
save the data that we need.
For example, let's
say we have an app
and we want to make
sure that our users are
European citizens over 18.
Instead of storing the user's
full birthday and country
of birth, we only need
to store, whether they
meet our two criteria.
As you design your app,
think about what data
you need for it to function
and what the amount of time
is that you need to
store this data for.
RACHEL MYERS: Woo.
Thanks.
Not everyone is starting
with a brand new project.
So if you have an
existing project,
you're not out of luck.
Let's look at some
privacy features
that we've added to an existing
app that we call Friendly Pics.
Friendly Pics is a
reference implementation
for many different features
implemented on Firebase.
And now, it includes
user privacy features.
It has a straightforward
user facing feature set.
It lets users sign
in, upload photos.
And then it has
some social features
like commenting and
favoriting photos.
The data that's stored
by Friendly Pics
all supports one of
these three features.
That stores account
information--
these are things that are in
addition to authentication data
that we get.
Next, Friendly Pics
stores the pictures
that users have uploaded.
A normal app might
keep this forever,
but for Friendly
Pics because we want
to show lots of
privacy features,
we delete all of the
photos after one month.
And finally, Friendly Pics
saves the social interactions
with these pictures.
These are things like
likes and comments.
And we keep them until those
things are deleted by the users
or until the photo it's
associated with is deleted.
So whether you're
writing a new app
or you're improving the privacy
of an existing application,
the first step to
managing your privacy
is to understand exactly
what data you're storing
and the features that
that data is supporting.
That will give you an
idea of how long you
need to support it.
It gives you a position to
start scripting the data removal
once you no longer need it.
So many organizations want to
limit the data they're storing.
And they only want to
keep the data they need.
And they only want to keep it
for as long as they need it.
Those are some
principles to live by.
And I want to stop
here and acknowledge
that it isn't always as easy as
you might think to delete data.
You might have a great
engineering proposal
for how you're going to remove
the data you no longer need.
And that could meet
with a lot of resistance
within the organization.
Maybe you have someone
in the org who hates
the idea of data going away.
For example, you have
an analytics person
that likes to run a
query for how many users
between the ages of 18-25 are
performing a particular action.
So you could run
that query, if you
know that they're doing this,
and save that daily count
on the number of users.
And then you can delete
the data associated
with individual users.
That way you keep your analytics
person happy and you also
keep your users happy.
So when you're auditing
the data that you
need across your organization,
be as specific as possible.
If you only need count
of the number of users,
make sure that you know that.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: Even if we
store only the minimum amount
of data, we should
still structure it
in a way that makes it
easy to delete it later.
To me, offering
users the ability
to delete their own data
is an important pillar
of user privacy.
You should delete
user data not only
when a user requests that
their account is being removed
but also when you no longer
need a specific set of data
for your app to function.
If you design your app
with user privacy in mind,
deleting user data can be
pretty simple with Firebase.
The asynchronous
nature of most deletes
makes deleting a great use case
for Google Cloud Functions,
a service that
should already be one
of the primary tools in
your Serverless tool belt.
While deletion is often
triggered by explicit actions
in your app-- as in this example
of a user deleting their post--
remember that you ultimately
don't control the requests that
come from your client.
You don't want to rely
solely on your customers
to clean up their own data.
To remove data that
is no longer needed,
you can instead create
a cloud function
that cleans up unneeded items.
RACHEL MYERS: Cloud
Functions for Firebase
are like programmatic glue.
It lets you extend and connect
all of the Firebase products
and all of the Cloud
products as well.
So you can create a completely
Serverless backend for your web
and your mobile applications.
Cloud Functions
are event driven.
They're lightweight JavaScript.
And this means that
they are deployed--
and this means that
when something happens,
it causes this function to run.
That's the way to
think about it.
So how do functions work?
All Cloud Functions are
triggered by some action
that is taken on your system.
This could be something
like an image is uploaded
or a user has
clicked this button.
In this case, let's say we
want to trigger a function when
a user logs in.
When that event occurs,
an event is emitted--
in this case from
Firebase authentication.
A new environment is spun
up that only has my code
and the dependencies that
I've declared for my code.
Then that code within
my function is executed.
In this example, say
when the user logs in,
my function will create
some default records
for the user in Firestore.
As another example, when
you delete a document
from Firestore, you can
trigger a custom function
that can cleanup all
of that related data.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT:
Sometimes it's
obvious when data is obsolete.
In Friendly Pics, for example,
we delete all comments
and likes when the user requests
that we delete a picture.
For other use cases,
it's not as apparent.
If your app has functionality
that only temporarily needs
some of its data, I'd recommend
deleting the unused items when
they are no longer needed.
An example of a case where
you only temporarily need data
is a high score list
in which you only
need to keep the highest scores
and not the complete history.
Friendly Pics really
is a good model here.
It doesn't keep any
data longer than 30 days
and uses a Cloud Function
to periodically delete
older items.
You can find an
article that explains
how to set up a cron
job to trigger a Cloud
Function at the
short link or you
can use the new Cloud
Scheduler to schedule
functions to run periodically.
RACHEL MYERS: You'll
also want to ensure
that you no longer
keep any user data when
users delete their accounts.
If using Firebase
Authentication,
you can call the delete API
from the Firebase User Object
to delete all of
that information.
But calling delete will not,
however, remove user data
that's stored in other
products, for example Firestore.
If you're going
Serverless, that cleanup
is a great use case
for Firebase Functions.
The function could either be
triggered by an authentication
delete event.
Or if you're not using
Firebase Authentication,
you can trigger the function
via an HTTP request.
We've done some of the work
to get you started here
by publishing a general
purpose account deletion
function that you
can tune to work
with exactly your data model.
So let's walk
through that quickly.
First, this is my function.
It lives in index.js.
When a user clicks the
delete account button,
that's going to call the delete
API in Firebase Authentication.
And that triggers
this function to run.
But my code is generalized here.
To make it work specifically
for this one app,
I needed to add a JSON file
called userprivacy.JSON that
lives in the Functions folder.
This file allows me to
delete the paths that
need to be removed when a
user deletes their accounts.
I can define the paths for
all the services that I use,
such as Firestore, Realtime
Database, and storage.
And I'm using a variable
here for the parts
of that that will be
replaced by the user's ID.
When the function is
triggered, I get the UID
from the event.dataobject.
And because I went
to remove data
from Firestore, the Realtime
Database, and storage,
I'm going to call
three helper functions.
If you're not using
one of these services,
you can easily
exclude that and not
include that unused function.
Each of the helper functions
share the same basic structure.
But let's walk through the
function from the Realtime
Database as an example.
First, I'm going to fetch the
relevant paths from the JSON
file.
And then I'm going to iterate
through each one of those,
removing the data at that path.
When each iteration returns,
I'm going to return control
to the top-level function.
Can I throw it to you?
Oh, OK.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: You may also
want to offer your user's data
portability.
Providing users a
copy of their data
in a well-known and
machine readable format
allows them to transfer their
data between different service
providers.
We've released another Cloud
Function called Export Data
that can help you with this.
The Export Data function is
triggered by an HTTP request
that you can make when the user
requests a copy of their data.
It calls three helper
functions that perform
the export for each product.
The helper function--
in this case,
the one for the
Realtime Database--
use the same user
privacy, the JSON
file that Rachel
just showed you.
You can use the exact
same configuration
or you can provide
separate path.
The helper functions
iterate through the schema
and exported JSON file that is
then uploaded to Cloud Storage.
It is incredibly
important that this
exported data in
Cloud Storage is
only accessible to the user
whose data you export it.
You can accomplish this
by using Firebase Security
Rules, the security model for
all the Firebase's products.
Since the export data function
uploads the exported data
to a location that includes
the user's user ID,
you can create a
security rule like this
which makes the data only
accessible to that user.
Remember, that it is essential
that you audit your security
rules if you're storing any
user data with Firebase.
With Firebase
Security Rules, if you
deny access in one
rule's expression
but grant access in
another, we combine them
and access is granted.
Make sure that you
understand that our rules are
ord together.
RACHEL MYERS: If you have a
more complicated data model that
can't be expressed as a list
of wildcard paths like the one
we have in our JSON
file, that's OK.
In that case, I would
suggest that you
maintain a list of locations
for the user's data.
And you can use that list as
the input for a similar Cloud
Function that,
just like this one,
iterates through those paths
and either deletes or copies
that data over,
depending on if you're
doing an export or a delete.
If you keep data
portability in mind
as you are building your app,
then deleting and exporting
data can be as
simple as configuring
one of these general
purpose functions.
Serverless development
can respect user privacy.
And we're making it
easier than ever.
With Cloud Functions
for Firebase,
you can manage your user's
data without building out
expensive infrastructure.
And we've published a guide
for clearing and removing
user's data.
You can find more
about it at this link.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT:
Let's recall how
security is handled in
the traditional backend
application.
In a, let's call it,
serverfull application,
there is a client,
a storage layer,
and an application layer.
The application
layer is often used
to enforce security
and access controls.
If a client sends a
malicious request,
the application layer
can drop the request.
In Serverless systems,
the application layer
has been removed.
The client connects directly
to the storage layer.
So we ask for the
Serverless system and force
access controls.
In Firebase, access
controls are enforced right
at the storage layer.
We validate every
incoming request
against the security
rules that you configured.
Security rules are
your first line
of defense in creating
secure Firebase apps.
And secure apps really
are an essential part
of treating your
user's data well.
And correctly configuring
security rules
is an important step in
preventing unauthorized data
access.
RACHEL MYERS: We've heard
from a lot of Firebase users
that security rules can be
intimidating or even confusing.
So we've invested a lot
of time, and energy,
and thought into creating
new products that
make it easier than ever.
So because security
rules are so important,
we want to spend a
little bit of time
in this talk walking through
some of the new features
that we've built
around security rules.
First, before you
deploy your rules,
you can try them
out and play around
with what you might want that
to look like in the Web Console.
There are simulators.
And they let you test
different types of requests.
So you can say for this type
of request, should it succeed?
And then you can test to
make sure it succeeds.
For a different
type of request, you
can test that it does fail
just like you want it to.
You can block access.
The simulators, though,
have a limitation.
They only help you as
you're writing the test,
as you're writing
your security rules.
What happens if last week,
Sebastian wrote great security
rules, and this week I
came around and tried
to improve them
and I accidentally
granted access to a lot of
people that I shouldn't have?
To make sure that you can have
confidence in your rules going
forward, we now offer a Security
Rules Emulator, simulator
and emulator, small
difference in words,
big difference in product.
And then the
emulators run locally.
So you can run this locally.
You can write tests
around what your rules do.
And then you can
include that as part
of your continuous
integration workflow.
They're npm tests.
You can include
them really easily
in what you're already running.
So check out the link
for more Information.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT:
The security rules
we've shown you today describe
a schema for your data
and spell out invariance
for your backend.
They allow you to limit not
only who can access your data,
but also limit how the data
itself relates to one another.
Please remember to never trust
the data from your client apps.
Since you no longer have
an application layer,
security rules are the best
way to enforce access controls.
Use the Security Rules Simulator
we offer in our Firebase Web
Console to help you write and
verify your security rules.
And use the new
Security Rules Emulator
to create automatic
tests around your rules.
RACHEL MYERS: Now,
we're ready to start
informing our users about the
data that will be collected.
At Firebase, we've published
a guide to our data retention
on our website.
And you can include
this information
as you inform your
users about what you're
doing with data collection.
The Firebase Data Privacy Terms
also explain what kind of data
each Firebase product collects,
how long that data is retained,
and how you can
delete that data.
And we've also
released a white paper
that explains what happened
inside of Google Cloud
when you invoke an
API to delete data.
This is more for
your information,
if you're curious than for
your data collection policies.
But if you'd like to see that,
it's available on the website
as well.
Thank you.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: When you
read our data privacy terms,
you may see that some Firebase
products like Cloud Messaging
or AB Testing have the ability
to identify individual devices.
This device level
identification is
done via Firebase Instance ID.
And it allows us to message
or change the experience
for only a subset of your users.
Because Firebase Instance
IDs are so important,
let's quickly go over them.
If you incorporate a product
that uses Firebase Instance
IDs, Firebase automatically
assigns a unique ID
to each app installation.
If you install two
different Firebase
apps on the same device, they
each have a different Instance
ID.
If you install the same app
on two different devices,
say an iPhone and an
iPad, they will also
have two different Instance IDs.
On the other hand, when
you restart the same app
on the same device, Firebase
keeps the same Instance ID.
That's how we can send
notifications to apps even when
they are not open.
While Instance ID
data is generally not
meant to be personally
identifying,
it can potentially be linked
to any personal profile data
that you store in
other products.
If you want to allow
your users to opt out
of this type of
data collection, you
can disable Instance
ID generation.
We have also added dedicated
APIs to our Admin SDKs
that let you delete the
Instance IDs themselves.
It is your responsibility
as a developer
to invoke these APIs when a
user requests account deletion.
For Firebase products that
key data by instance ID,
at the time it takes to remove
this data varies by product.
And you can find
more information
on this in our privacy terms.
RACHEL MYERS: Keep in
mind that deleting data
from our backend system
does not immediately
delete all copies of that data.
Some of it lives in backup
systems and caches temporarily.
So you can look at the terms
to understand more about when
it will be completely deleted.
So now that we
understand the data
that Google is
saving and retaining
and you have in mind
the data that you need
to support the features
that you've written,
let's talk about
how to inform users
and give them all
the information
they need to make a
meaningful decision.
In Friendly Pics,
we've added a notice
to let users know what
kind of data is being saved
and what features
that data supports.
This notice gives them
a choice if they'd
like us to save that
data or if they'd
like to disable that feature.
And features are only
enabled for the users
that want that data saved.
They'd have to actively
check to make sure
that that data will be saved.
For example, if a
user doesn't want
us to share their
social data, we
remove the ability to
add comments altogether.
If the user doesn't want us
to store any data at all,
Friendly Pics still has a
really good read-only mode.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: Depending
on how much of your app's
functionality is
handled by our backends,
you may also need to
process the user's privacy
settings in Firestore or
in the Realtime Database.
When you consider
structuring this data,
you should look at
how it will be read
and what privacy controls
your backend actually needs.
You'll likely want to make sure
that these settings are stored
in a place where you can
prevent unauthorized access
by other users.
For example, if your user's
profile information is public,
you probably want different
access restrictions
to these privacy
related settings.
You can use a layout
such as the one here
which contains a private
profile section in addition
to a public one.
Alternatively, you could store
their privacy preferences
in a separate section of
your database altogether.
RACHEL MYERS: You also want
to build a way for users
to update their
privacy settings.
This allows you to build
new features over time
or to modify existing features.
It's one thing, however, to let
people update their settings.
And it's another thing to think
through the process of what
you'll do with your data
when those settings change.
For example, say a user
grants consent for us
to save their photos and
then they change their mind.
What should we do with
the existing photos
that we've already saved?
This balance between user
expectations and user privacy
is different in
every application.
In Friendly Pics, we decided
to keep the existing pictures
in case the user wants
to see those still.
They can still delete
them on their own
or we'll delete all of them
when they delete their account.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT: As users
change their consent settings,
you may also want to keep
a record of these changes
in an activity log.
An activity log allows you
to share security or privacy
related changes with
your users and gives them
the ability to monitor
changes to their accounts.
If you're storing
privacy settings
in Firestore or in
the Realtime Database,
this is another good case
for Google Cloud Functions.
With Cloud Functions,
Firebase can automatically
maintain an activity
log for you.
It's straightforward to
create a small function that
is triggered every time a
user's privacy settings change
and which then copies
the new settings
to an append only
storage location.
Here's an example of
an activity logger
that listens to changes in the
privacy collection of Firestore
and adds entries to a dedicated
activity log collection.
If you want to make sure that
this activity log is append
only and cannot be modified,
you can use Security Rules
to prevent any changes.
For example, if your activity
log uses the Firestore
collection for each
user and a document
for each time a user
changes their settings,
you can use a rule like this
which allows document creation
but doesn't allow
updates of existing data.
We've created a guide
to storing and using
privacy settings
in Firebase that
explains how to automatically
maintain activity logs.
You can find a link
to it on this slide
or on the Firebase website.
RACHEL MYERS: So building
privacy features,
like secure access
controls, data portability,
and data cleanup, can be within
easy reach of every developer
using Serverless architectures.
Many of the privacy features
that we've pointed out today
can be easily deployed
to Cloud Functions.
And we've shown how you
can lock down your data
using Firebase Security Rules.
We hope that the tools and
technology we've highlighted
can help you turn user privacy
into some of the easiest
features that you
put on your app.
SEBASTIAN SCHMIDT:
GDPR is not the first
and it will certainly not be
the last piece of legislation
that changes how we
handle user data.
The ever growing list of
user privacy regulations
can seem really daunting.
And it makes touching any
kind of data really difficult.
But let's all take a
step back, and let's
instead focus on doing the
right thing for our users.
If we treat our users'
data with respect,
if we make sure our data
retention policies are
easy to understand, if we
limit the amount of data
that we handle, and if we
offer our users the ability
to make meaningful
decisions about the data
that they lend to us, then
we'll likely be in a good place
no matter what privacy
regulations the future
may bring.
Come find us later at the
Firebase booth in the Expo.
We'd love to talk
to you about how
you can be responsible
with your users' data.
Remember that we
can't help us lawyers
but we can help you as friends.
RACHEL MYERS: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]